tonight it's tyler glass now on the hill
for the rain working here tonight with a
couple of extra days of rest could have
started in that series against the
rangers but instead the rays decide with
the off day push him back give him a
little bit more time you know this is a
guy that you want to make 30 plus starts
and be ready for the postseason so take
the rest when you can get it oh kyle
schwarber
a lot of experience up there justin in
the lead-off spot maybe not a lot but
more than you might expect and he's had
some success with power performances
when he's the lead-off hitter
and cutting the miss or the fastball
right down central to 98.
he saved a couple miles an hour there to
be able to put schwarber away
turner fourth leading hitter in the
national league at 3 11.
2-2 pitch strength three call with a
fastball he's had enough of the breaking
stuff got him looking at 98 and there's
two men retired
that's a shot into center field
kiermeier is going to have room and he
puts it away
no runs ahead in the man left
here's john lester eighth start of the
season still looking for his first win
as last time out on short rest good
manuel margot he's going to be leading
it off
that's a high shot
deep to left that baby is gone
home run for margot
sixth home run of the season for manuel
margot and that's the sixth home run
given up by john lester in 35 innings
pitched with 419 feet came off the back
at about 106 and
when cutters don't cut
they get uh barreled up one nothing ray
bell is the dh today having it just 217.
and a tapper toward the middle of the
infield walls is there and the throw is
going to be in time
keeping his foot on the bag on the reach
toward right field diaz to retire bell
harrison he's a guy right now three for
his last 23. just swinging a miss and a
ball in the dirt strike three ceno's got
him throws him out and there is another
strikeout
issues his first walk walking wendell
now mike zunino raised catcher number
seven entering 197 for the year 24 hits
throw down by gomes right on the money
and yet again
a nationals catcher has caught a runner
trying to swipe a bag that's joey
wendell caught stealing
second walk in a row and of the inning
so with two out now zadino the runner at
first and taylor walls
switch hitting shortstop coming
up all on the ground is short turner an
off-balance throw and the scoop attempt
will not be successful the raise will
continue this ending this throw by trey
turner he did not get a lot on it this
ball dies about halfway there bounces
this one
out towards schwarber
robles right behind him as the nationals
left fielder makes the grab so the rays
threaten in the second but cannot score
the nationals have two on for trey
turner gotta find ways to drive in these
runners that they have on base runners
lead second and first glass now checks
the runner fires
fastball line drive right center field
base hit one off to kiermeier castro is
going to try to score keermeyer's throw
is up the third base line castro's in
standing and the nationals have tied the
game schwarber holds it second trey
turner drives in his 30th run of the
year and this game is tied at one here
in the third inning
a little number that's going to go
through the open right side
diaz digging hard he's going to go to
third without a play
and it will be on the corners for the
raise first and third cube it on with
two med out for mike brasso
popped up right field soda will move
back just a few steps
and he has it
strike three call
and uh zimmerman
is not happy with laz diaz they're
having a little bit of a prolonged
conversation right there i i think he's
asking him to wait a minute is that on
me or is that on the call did you call
on my swing did you call it on this
you're wrong either way but which way
did you go in and the o2 pitch breaking
ball swung on missed strike three and
tyler glass now just made quick work for
the next teammate who's two outs six
strikeouts now for tyler with two outs
here on the fourth
swinging and damascus harrison
out on strikes
he comes out with the bases loaded two
down wonders sure
comes on for the 20th time he's got a
strikeout and inning just three walks
and yandy diaz pretty good up there at
the plate and he's swinging the bat well
recently the 3-2
another one popped out to center robles
over to his left says he has it
and the nationals are out of a jam in
the fourth
and there's a wave and a pitch in the
dirt andrews on a turn walk away
[Music]
you want to talk about lack of pitch
recognition and not being able to pick
up spin
this ball comes out of the hand and he's
already swinging
he misses that ball by feet
and he got a strike three bottom of the
zone
98 down there
he strikes out the side 10 strikeouts
through five for glass now
back to back walks the bronzo is going
to be the hitter he throws de brusso
line drive down the right field line
long run for soto coming in and it drops
along the fair line and then gets by him
and rolls out to the bullpen rounding
through his meadows and he will score or
arena to third and up the second is
brussel and the rays take a 2-1 lead
genina has walked both times up
and there's a line guard base hit into
center
perez arena will score rousseau around
third going to put on the brakes there
now the rbi single
the rays make it three to one
so harper the right-hander
with the bases loaded will face
manuel margot
there's a curveball
margot left is it fair
oh kyle schwarber
a catch over the short wall
in foul territory
didn't matter if it was fair didn't
matter if it was battle it ended up in
kyle schwarber's glove
with one out here is juan soto
did he go he started to got that bat
back
and then what about the little shimmy by
soto these shimmy mechanics right here
the stair and then the lower half shimmy
and the left
catchable for roxarena
is behind 3-1 now
bell squares this one up out to right
field it'll one hop the wall and kick
away from manny margot
josh bell will cruise in the second base
with a lead off double here in the
seventh so here's josh harrison now with
one out the 1-1 pitch loop toward left
is going to get down for a base hit
might score a run late break from second
for bell a rose arena up with at the
throat of the plate and did they get him
yes they
did bell tries to score from second
the rays get the call
nationals want to review this
did he get there in time you know that
front leg was leading the way but kind
of watch it curl back and not go right
to the plate
i don't think you could overturn that he
is out at the plate you're right though
dave a better slide and he's in for ball
fortis turner puts two men on with one
out and juan soto will be the batter the
kick and the pitch too high outside ball
four and the bases are loaded with
nationals zimmerman's fly to deep left
center struck out of the check swing
popped to second all against the starter
tyler glass now the two-strike pitch and
he strikes him out
fast ball up so now up to josh bell
who's bounced to short struck out and
double to right
struck him out swinging
fastball takes care of josh bell
castillo trying to save this thing for
tyler glassnell who would pick up his
fifth win
0-2
and the rays win it 3-1 a swing and miss
castro out on strikes and the rays come
away with game one of this series